welcome everyone to another episode of
firm learning and today i want to talk
about how to dress like a consultant and
of course we all know that consultants
like to wear suits shirts sometimes also
ties so in today's video i do want to go
beyond the obvious and also talk about
the more subtle differences the less
obvious things that do matter though and
really can make a difference when you
choose your wardrobe for consulting this
video focuses on the mail wardrobe since
the gentleman edition i might also
create a video about female wardrobe in
the future let me know in the comments
whether this would be a topic you're
interested in as well i might need some
female support on that though the topic
i want to connect this to is maybe a
little bit controversial so feel free to
provide your opinion your views also in
the comments but it is at least my
humble observation that in especially
mbb firms so these leading strategy
consulting firms mckinsey bcg bane and
the like the quota of people with a
working-class background so the quota of
people of first generation academics is
rather low so the question of course is
why is this the case surely there are no
hard criteria in the interviews
discriminating against these kinds of
backgrounds it seems clear to me though
that at least in academia these types of
phenomena are well described there's
also a very famous sociologist called
pierre boudier who coined the term
habitus so describes how different
people have different habituals which
can be loosely translated to social
status the peer body is very explicit
that this status is to be defined far
beyond only money so there's much more
to it than just your financial means and
a big part of it is also your cultural
capital so for instance how to dress in
certain situations and maybe also how
not to dress in certain situations and
this is arguably a knowledge that people
with certain backgrounds maybe lack
because of course this is not something
that you will learn during your business
administration studies these are often
things that you really learn at home
maybe from your parents from your peers
of course everyone knows that you need
to wear a suit a shirt maybe a tie to
your job interview but people often lack
the understanding beyond that right so
what type of suit are you supposed to
wear what type of shirt are you supposed
to wear so these are exactly the things
i want to help you with today these fine
distinctions as pia body would call it
that really can have a very significant
impact on you personally and also
professionally so let's start with the
suits so what suits should you wear and
just to provide a little bit of context
i also want to talk about a slightly
more formal tire and how this fits into
the bigger picture of what you should
wear as a consultant i think the first
thing to understand is that usually for
menswear you distinguish evening attire
and daytime attire so let's start with
formal evening attire and they're
usually three types of suits dress suits
that you wear as a man the most formal
one is a tail coat so this is what often
is described as a white tie dress code a
tail coat sometimes worn for gala
dinners frankly rather rarely really
used today but that's the most formal
tire that you can wear as a man the
second most formal and this is maybe
something that some of you have also
more experience with is a tuxedo so
tuxedo are things that you will also
wear often this is worn again more usual
regular gala events often also in the
evening of a wedding for instance a
tuxedo would be
something like
this now we can make just a video about
that and i don't want to go too much
into the details of how a tuxedos may be
different from a more regular suit but
surely i hope it's clear that you will
not wear neither a tail coat nor a
tuxedo as a consultant and the number
three for the more formal evening
attires is a black suit so if a tuxedo
maybe a little bit too much and you're
on a very formal event in the evening
you might want to wear a black suit so
that's the evening attire and now let's
talk about the daytime attire and
daytime usually means until about 6 pm
so that's the logic that you will hear
and the most formal daytime attire is a
cutaway so probably also contrasted to a
tailcoat cutaways also cuts as many
people like to call them are still
rather common you often see them at more
formal weddings during the daytime so
that's number one the card the number
two most formal is called the strazerman
also called a black launch suit i will
likely insert a picture somewhere here
because frankie also don't have one and
then number three is a black suit as
well so where do i want to get it
because indeed all these things are not
what you will wear usually as a
consultant and the error that some
people are doing is that they are
wearing a black suit to their regular
consulting job this is a typical error
because again black suits are usually
formal attire for formal events not for
your day-to-day business not for your
day-to-day clothing so what type of suit
should you wear instead well these are
darker suits that are not black though
the typical colors would be an
anthracite so dark anthracite color
another typical color would be just a
dark gray tone for instance something
like this that you could wear or also a
dark blue personally i really like dark
blue just in general as a color and also
for suits i think this often fits really
well next let's talk about shirts
because for sure there are many errors
that you can make with shirts and the
first thing that maybe comes to mind is
a plain white shirt
so can you wear a plain white shirt and
here i'd say
yes but maybe it's not the best choice i
mean first of all truth is also an mbb
film so maybe especially mbb firms many
people wear white shirts so this is for
sure not uncommon you will see many
people wearing them but now linking this
back to this point on more formal attire
traditionally plain white shirts are
shirts that are worn for formal attire
and indeed so what should you wear
instead so let me just show a couple of
examples so usually what's recommended
maybe rather instead of a plain white is
a simple light blue so be careful here
with the tone of blue the tone really
matters in principle you want to go with
a very light blue like this so this
would be a good alternative another nice
touch
is a light stripe
something like this so blue and white
stripes this also makes a very nice
day-to-day shirt that you can very well
wear also during business times
where for instance you should be a bit
careful just to provide an example
it's a shirt like this
this is also blue and probably still
borderline okay but notice how this blue
already is a little bit darker than this
other blue i'm not sure whether you can
see it well in the video but this blue
is a little bit darker and this directly
makes it a little bit more sportive and
again we don't want to go with too much
of sportive shirts in these occasions
but now let's talk about patterns of
shirts and i do think that you can also
wear patterns which are maybe a little
more extravagant than just simple
stripes so let's look at an example like
this again not sure where you can see it
in the video but this is a very light
light blue pad and it is a bit more
complex though with more cross type of
things in here
while this is very light i'd say this is
still okay here the point is how visible
these patterns are and again let's
contrast that for instance with a shirt
like this
with no very very bold stripes pattern
this is too much this is too sportive
this is not a type of shirt that you
should wear let's talk about something
else and this is now the collar and here
also one very typical error and now here
i'm deliberately choosing this shirt
which is already sportive is this type
of collar with two buttons in the color
this type of color is called a button
down color
so if you wear this the first very big
faux pas is if you wear such a shirt
without closing down your buttons of the
color so this is just an absolute logo
this is has not only to do with
consulting but also just in your leisure
and so on button down shirts are always
supposed to be worn with closed buttons
here at the collar but i would even go
one step beyond and to say that this
type of collar in general is considered
to be a very sportive color type so i
would claim that in general shorts with
a button-down color should not be worn
in more you know formal considering
day-to-day business attire let's not
talk about shirts with colored buttons
so here again you see a very sportive
version of a shirt see how most border
versions more often come also with
button down again it just fits it
because it's also sport of color type
but in detail with this example you have
these dark black buttons but one thing
that i think is just just don't do it
you see quite frequently are shirts that
maybe are even white right so white
shirts which makes them already very
formal and then they come with for
instance black buttons or somehow
colored buttons and i guess maybe some
people believe that this is like a great
stylistic choice here again just don't
do it so now let's next talk about the
cuffs of your shirt and probably the two
most common variations are so called
barrier cuffs so more sportive ones and
also double cuffs so i need to look at
the screen to know all these english
terms but here the simple double cuff
would be something like this so a cuff
that then you fold
and then put together then connect via
cufflinks
so this is usually the more formal type
of cuffs and the other type that is
considered the more sportive one is the
single cuff or berry cuff as i learned
it's called in english and that's the
cuff where just with simple buttons
without folding them you can connect
them today it's very common to just wear
these simple cuffs also for your shirt
so this is absolutely fine this is
absolutely what you can wear to be aware
if you want to be a bit more formal a
bit more dressy
these types of cuffs the double cuffs
work as well and then of course you have
the opportunity to combine this with
some cufflinks which is a nice way of
having some jewelry maybe even as a man
on your cuffs i don't want to go here
too much into the detail surely don't
overdo it with your cufflinks right i
mean you can be extremely extravagant i
mean he'll also choose maybe some more
simple more decent motives but i trust
in general that's an important
distinction to know this way let's now
discuss ties and here probably the
reality also for mbb consulting is the
ties are not that commonly worn anymore
and here often you will adjust a little
bit more to the client office or what
the clients is doing if they're wearing
ties then you will likely verify as well
probably the majority of the clients i
worked for that we didn't need to wear a
tie but even if you don't need to wear a
tie i think it's always the best
practice to have a tie in your bag if
maybe on short notice you need to join
another location maybe join a workshop a
meeting whatever maybe even at another
client that you're ready to wear a tie
whenever this is a quiet so if you do
wear a tie similar with the other things
i would choose more plain more regular
colors here for instance dark green dark
blue some very light more decent motives
surely are okay as maybe here you see
this very light green and blue motif
that you see here on this tie but this
is what i would go for
surely i would be a bit careful when
your motives are more colorful more
playful maybe like something like this
this would be a more sportive tie that
probably is not the best fit for
consulting so let's now talk about the
shoes because surely this is also an
important part of your outfit and here
frankly i would in general just go with
dark black shoes this is where you
usually will not go wrong so very
classical typical shoe type like this i
believe these are called oxfords now
probably the real experts in the
comments will tell me that this is not
right or maybe quite differently let me
know here i'd be interested but this is
just a very typical nice format maybe a
little bit more sportive are these
brogues i believe they're called also
similar with a bit more appliances here
at the top part of the shoe so this for
sure is absolutely fine you can wear
this we would be a bit careful our brown
shoes well this to some extent can be
okay as well it often looks very
sportive and it requires a little bit
more of stylistic command to really
combine them in the right way if you do
want to be a bit more extravagant surely
there are also some other models like
some nice monks for instance they can
work quite well i will try to include a
couple of pictures here for these types
of shoes but if in doubt go for very
nice clean simple oxfords and you will
do nothing wrong let's our next talk
about baits because usually you will use
belts to hold your suit into position
some suits don't require one but i'd say
most of them that you will buy do until
there's one very basic and simple rule
and this is that the belt should have
both the color and the material of the
shoes that you're wearing the color and
the material of the shoes that you're
wearing so if you just follow my
recommendation and go with very plain
and black leather shoes then just pick a
plain black leather belt and you will be
fine if you do choose brown shoes then
of course also choose a brown belt if
you go for bug skin material make sure
that your belt is from box skin leather
as well again collar and material of
your shoes and your belt should match
this is the very basic simple rule that
you should follow so last but not least
let's talk about accessories so what are
the additional things that you can wear
we already talked about cufflinks
another big question that i often get
are pocket squares so should you wear
pocket squares or not the idea of pocket
squares is that this is something that
you might be able to put here into the
pocket of your suit so you see this
sometimes my general recommendation here
would be to not do it in consulting i
think it's very unusual only very very
few people will do it my general
recommendation for these more business
type of situations would be to not wear
pocket squares and not use pocket
squares like this and last but not least
another point are the watches so i think
a watch of course is always something
that nicely complements a man's a
gentleman's outfit so of course you need
to be a bit careful with what type of
watch you are wearing so what's very
popular and i think no problem at all
are smart watches so for instance you
own an apple watch that truly no problem
at all and can also be quite handy for
checking emails checking your calendar
and so on if you want to wear a more
traditional mechanical watch that's of
course absolutely okay as well just two
recommendations that i would give you
from my humble experience is first i
probably would avoid watches this cost
more than 10 thousand euro or ten
thousand dollars or very expensive
watches again in general you want to
avoid creating the impression in front
of your clients that you are extremely
rich extremely loaded and then also
second
certain brands even though maybe there
are below 10 000 euro just to provide a
very general threshold they are a bit
controversial and they are associated
with certain thoughts that some people
have so i think here the classical one
are rolex watchers i think in general
rolex watches are great i can understand
why many people like them but maybe if
you have one rather keep it to yourself
or your leisure time maybe with your
friends if you hang out in the evening
but maybe not during your work day if
you work in consulting again this might
just create the wrong impression for you
and i hope you can see my point from the
beginning that to say it with pierre
boudier the differences can often be
quite subtle but i would be interested
in your opinion i mean do you agree i by
no means want to claim that i am the
biggest fashion master happy to also
learn more about these things from you
as always if you took any value out of
this video at all please hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to stay up to date with
all my content big big thanks to all the
members of the channel thank you for
supporting the course my name is
heinrich here on my channel i release
weekly content every saturday so see you
again next week until then all the best
to you and bye bye